you know it's actually an amazing story
I've looked into it you guys make films
but at the moment now I think together
and separately you're responsible for
like 65 really good shows 66 66 okay
incredible and and what amazes me is Jay
in transparent mark the league how is it
working as brothers I mean you you guys
work together closely yeah I have a lot
of brothers and I know what it's like
how there can be sometimes conflicting
emotions and I'm imagine you guys we
keep it tight okay we don't do that
where I'm like contacting me let alone
hold hands
I mean people find it impossible to
believe that we get along but you know
for us making a movie is kind of like
creating a monster I'm a monster that
threatens to destroy your happiness so
when you have this like beast that's
like threatening your happiness at all
times it's great to have your brother by
your side so we like to gang up against
Frankenstein basically right not no one
man can kill Franken yeah and then if we
disagree we just break out the ping-pong
table and destroy each other like normal
brothers oh really yeah again we don't
do that where I'm from either that
ping-pong settles all bets in our family
we use sticks sticks with nails in them
now this is weird
Jay you directed mark in a sex scene
this year that's true on togetherness
and I have to think it would be odd to
be directing your brother in such an
intimate way it's it's al it's a little
weird I mean just for my part because we
also do some improvisation on our sets
so there was this one specific scene
where my wife played by melanie lynskey
and I were having a lovemaking scene Jay
was on the camera and it was a closed
set with the three of us you know and
and as we were progressing Jay was like
okay mark go ahead and and and and put
your hand again on Melanie's boob like
he did last time and and we did it and
we executed the scene and then all of us
sort of like realized the complete
awkwardness of what had just happened it
was it it was a very long drive home
that night for all yes there was all of
you realize he had no camera
it's just sketching it bere
yeah there was also a spanking scene
where again Melanie's character is
spanking Marc's character no I saw this
scene in mark it looked like you were
pretty much completely new and totally
naked
he was totally I was not wearing
clothing now we did a great job with our
camerawork and editing to you know
reduce the the balls exposure further
for the viewing audience however in the
room that day it was all balls all day
it was balls and Palooza basically now
see a real my real friend of mine a real
brother of mine would enhance the balls
he would not if my brother came to me
and said you know let's see where you're
naked I completely got rid of your
genitalia I'd be like what the hell use
that machine that in Lord of zanbar make
it bigger yeah exactly order I would
want light coming off of it and music
playing what did you wear in that scene
because you had to be wearing something
legally or else you're just making porn
it's tricky because if being naked the
only thing weirder than being naked
sometimes is wearing the weird nudity
garments yeah I walked into my dressing
room and that I had two options one was
it's called the dance belt which is
basically I've worn it like you've worn
the dance belt are you wearing one right
now this is all I'm wearing that's my
pants come off after the monologue yeah
and and I mean it for those of you don't
know the dance ball it's basically just
like a new kind of male song which is
uncomfortable nobody wins with write a
spell then they have this other thing
which is this little little baggie that
we we call the coin purse which yeah you
kind of oh it has a little drawstring
and you open it up and you stuff all
your elements inside it's like you pull
the string close it's like the nude
Crown Royal liquor bag
that good that could be an embarrassing
mishap right there where's my Crown
Royal there it is
everyone's selling their Crown Royal
stock right now dump it dump it
you